Paraparkter today told me about something he called bone panel
blood work that's supposed to tell you what his affecting bone tissue
and differentiates between damage likely from cancer or rickets etc. Have you ever heard of this?
He suggested as a baseline to keep closer tab. I didn't ask him what the labs are included yet.
Okay, so just understand if you have bone loss. So if you do a test for those tests for
osteoporosis and osteopetia that shows your percentage of bone loss, that is I never have ever
recommended those tests. I just don't see a whole lot of value in those. I don't think that's
what he's talking about here. If you have bone loss, let's say it's bone loss ceta x-ray or bone
loss ceta cat scan or cat scan, cat scan would show metabolic activity, but bone loss ceta or CT scan
or x-ray. You have quite a bit of bone loss. You would know if you had rickets or something like
that. When you're doing a differential diagnosis of why a person has bone loss, you're looking at
that person's history, you're looking at other things. If I had bone loss due to osteoporosis or
osteopetia, I would not show an elevated alkaline phosphatase nor show an elevated calcium. You're
only going to get an elevated alkaline phosphatase and an elevated calcium if you have rapid
destruction of bone. So osteopetia and osteoporosis is not a rapid destruction of bone. So I don't know
the value of any kind of bone handle blood work. I don't know exactly what this person is talking
about. So I don't know any value of that. So when you're contemplated, you know, why I might have
changes in my blood work, you go through a differential diagnosis of trying to figure that out. Let's
say if I have bone cancer and I have elevated or rising alkaline phosphatase levels and rising
calcium levels, that's a clue in the clue that that should give you is that there can be destruction.
So you could have elevated alkaline phosphatase and that's going to be found in your liver panel,
which would be a simple metabolic panel or a comprehensive metabolic panel. So you'd have an
elevated alkaline phosphatase and elevated a rising high level of calcium. That's going to be
suggestive of bony destruction. Now you can't have an elevated alkaline phosphatase due to
destruction of other tissues too. Most commonly would be liver, but then you'd also most likely have
elevated AST and ALT. So those are the kind of the things that you look at when you're looking
at your lab work. My ALT is elevated, my AST is elevated, my alkaline phosphatase is elevated,
that I go, huh, do I have, do I have possible? With the history of cancer, do I possibly have
metastasis to my liver, or do I possibly have toxicity to my liver? What am I taking that could
cause toxicity to liver and die, die, die out of 100 times, it's going to be a medication. So even
over the counter medication, like Tylenol, or adbil, or Phenbenazole can cause those things. So
when you, if that's why I ask if you're on Phenbenazole, or Ivermectin, or you're taking Tylenol,
or you're doing that, those things that make sure you're getting a liver panel to be able to look
at those numbers to know that you're not getting toxicity to the liver. So that's kind of how you go
through that, then if you think, okay, come through a differential diagnosis, there's something,
I don't, not on any type of medications, I do have a history of cancer, and my liver numbers are
rising, and my calcium numbers are rising, then it might be time to get a PET scan done to see where there's
metabolic activity. And if the PET scan shows positive to the liver, or shows positive to the bone,
then then you could say, well, that's probably why these numbers work up. So that's how you kind of put
the whole picture together, when you're going through this process called differential diagnosis.
So all tests give you clues, and you just need to know how to read those clues. Now, if everything
I said to you is common knowledge, that's great, but if everything I said to you is like, what did
you say? I have videos, I don't know all this stuff. So, okay, well, what did this alkaline
phosphatase mean? Well, that's a, that's a figure on your, on your, um, cup of heads and metabolic
pedal. Well, I have blog posts on that, it's called elevated alkaline phosphatase. What can this
mean? So I go through that, and there's a video, multiple videos on that blog post because I've spoken
about this multiple times, so then you can see what a normal range is. See what, um, you know,
to go through this yourself too. So now, I want you guys to use the zoom calls for these questions.
So these are brilliant questions. And, and, um, but I also, what the whole purpose of these
zoom calls is for you guys to get smarter and smarter and smarter. So you can educate your family
and help take care of your family and, and help yourself and help your family and your loved ones
that's the whole purpose of these. And I, you know, we might, at least one of my purposes in life
is to, you know, try to educate people and teach people when I learned something. So I just try to,
you know, make videos and put that out there. So utilize our, our blogs for these, for all of that
too, because you learn a lot and I'll let you to be very wise.